now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right number one let me start with
this um
first of all can i just say at the
outset that i
i love controversies as much as the next
guy
more than the next guy probably uh i
live for it
it's great people fighting disagreeing
getting all offended about stuff
i'm into it i really am but every once
in a while
a controversy pops up that i just can't
get into i can't bring myself to care
and we are in one of those news cycles
right now and it's really killing me
this postal service stuff there's a lot
of controversy surrounding the postal
service
and mail-in voting and i i
i can't even continue talking about it
right now because i might fall asleep in
the middle of speaking that's how boring
it is to me
i've tried working myself up about it i
really have i've practiced it i was in
the more
the mirror this morning practicing like
getting angry ah this
the postal service i'm so angry
and i couldn't i just couldn't do it i
tried so um
here i am left out while people care
about this for 37 seconds
but it's a torturous 37 seconds because
i feel so excluded
but all of that said i did appreciate
this at least this was um
the the closest i could come to being
interested which is right here
you can see the footage a protest at the
postmaster general's house
these are people who are concerned that
their ability to vote by mail
is being blocked by trump and the
general i don't know if he's a real
general but uh
anyway that's what i call him but the
funny thing of course is that
they want to do mail-in voting because
they don't want to have to go out in
public and vote because they're afraid
of the virus
yet they're out in public in a large
group protesting
that they might have to be out in public
in a much smaller group to vote so it's
just
it's it's this is really this is part of
the scientific
discovery process that's been very
interesting
uh really really fascinating frankly to
learn more and more about this virus
each day
because at first we thought you know
it's a virus
it can infect anyone really you know
certain demographics are not as
susceptible of course like children
but you figure like it's it's sort of
it's just a virus you know that and
that's what you think but then then we
learned
that it really only infects you at
church at school
or during anti-lockdown protests or
while voting in person
but it doesn't infect you at walmart at
target
at blm protests or while protesting
voting in person so like i said
fascinating stuff
and this is why i just love science i
love learning
things like this it really is just a lot
of fun
number two here's a better controversy
this is more my speed father james
martin
jesuit of course is going to be speaking
at the dnc
i think on thursday martin despite being
a catholic priest is known for his
far-left activism
and in fact as a catholic it pains me to
say that
we might be reaching a point where i
don't need to say despite anymore in
that sentence but anyway
um this is the guy for example who sent
out a tweet
after george floyd died asking for
george floyd to intercede for us in
heaven
he literally tried to canonize george
floyd via tweet
he's also a big lgbt activist big into
leftist causes in general so
on one level it makes sense for him to
speak at the dnc but on another level
he's allegedly a catholic and allegedly
a priest
and you can't really be either of those
in good standing and have anything to do
with the modern democrat party the
modern democrat party is expressly
opposed
to catholic teaching christian teaching
biblical teaching
and there are of course many examples of
this but we don't need to go any further
than the democrat party's
stated official position that children
in the womb
at any stage and for any reason
can be executed so martin should be
defrocked and excommunicated for this he
won't be
of course but he should be number three
a few weeks ago
i had to cancel ryan reynolds because
he issued a public apology for getting
married
at a wedding venue um that uh
you know you almost we might be reaching
a point where i could just stop the
sentence there
where you're gonna have celebrities
apologizing
at least heterosexual celebrities
apologizing for getting married
in general uh we we might we might be
reaching that point but we're not there
yet so he got
he apologized for for getting married at
a wedding venue
that used to be a slave plantation 150
years ago
he apologized for that for some reason
because apparently now
you know you can't uh even if a place is
a very pretty venue and there's a lot of
great scenery
if bad stuff happened there a century
and a half ago you're not allowed to get
married
there um so you know before you
get married anywhere or really go do
anything anywhere like go for a picnic
anything
um you need to research do wikipedia go
to google maybe do an archaeological dig
to see what happened and then you can
have your picnic
um but now reynolds is begging to be
canceled again really the premier of
british columbia for some reason
held a press conference begging ryan
reynolds and seth rogen to help him
fight the coronavirus
because of course in a medical crisis
the people you want to call
are the guy from deadpool and the guy
from knocked up
here's here's the premiere i've been
talking about the importance of making
sure that younger demographics are
hearing the message
this is a call out to deadpool right now
uh ryan
we need your help up here uh get in
touch with us my number's
on the internet uh seth rogen another
outstanding british columbian
we need to communicate with people who
aren't hearing us the two of you alone
could help us in that regard
there's a host of other options
available and we're working as hard as
we can
to enlist a number of prominent british
columbians and prominent canadians
to help get that message through to the
demographic that clearly isn't hearing
our message
now reynolds in true cringe fashion
responded with for some reason a fake
voicemail
uh and this is what that sounded like
oh uh hey uh premier horgan ryan
reynolds here uh
i got your message about the thing
uh i'm not sure it's a great idea
frankly uh people don't i don't think
they want medical advice from guys like
me
no sir um unless it's plastic surgery
which a lot of people don't know this
but i used to be hugh jackman
uh you know young folks in bc yeah
they're they're
partying um which is of course dangerous
uh and they probably don't know that
that thousands of
young people aren't just getting sick
from coronavirus that they're they're
also dying from it too
uh and of course it's the terrible that
it affects our most vulnerable
you know bc is that's home to some of
the coolest older people on earth i mean
david suzuki
did he lives there my mom
she doesn't want to be cooped up in her
apartment all day she wants to be out
there
cruising kitsilano beach looking for
some young 30-something abercrombie
burnout to go full mrs robinson on
she is insatiable but here's the thing
um i hope that young people in bc don't
kill my mom
frankly or david suzuki or each other
let's not like let's not kill anyone i
think that's reasonable
uh and you know but i just i i don't
think that i'm the guy to deliver this
message i love
parties i mean my favorite thing to do
is just
sit alone in my room with a glass of gin
in the first 32 seasons of gossip girl
that's a party threw my shoulder out the
last time i did that
no one is going to kill your mother ryan
you paranoid lunatic
how people are partying okay um
if your mom's not going to those parties
then she should be all right
uh you know if she's going out and po if
you know if she's practicing social
distancing wearing the mask
you know it's it's i i i don't think
they're gonna
kill your mom i think i think it should
be really okay uh especially if she's
out on the beach
um out in the you know open air
keeping a distance i think everything
will be fine
number four here's a a report from
the new york post it says
uh twitter is raging over a supposed
call to cancel
genghis khan all prompted by a woman who
had merely pointed out that the fearless
12th century mongol
conqueror had also killed an awful lot
of people this is tweeted from user
priya 27 said genghis khan did to
central asia what islamic invaders did
to india maybe worse he single-handedly
killed 11 percent of the world
population at the time
yet some want to glorify him as a hero
and conqueror
that's your personal choice but
objectively genghis khan was a barbarian
i i saw these tweets now this is this
was tweeted out uh i thought
some interesting facts and points that
were made uh that
the 11 of the world population figure
i'd have to you know that's
that seems rather incredible i'd have to
go check that one myself but
anyway that's he certainly killed a lot
of people we know that and uh and then
people were mocking this though as if
she was trying to cancel
genghis khan posthumously um i don't
think that was the point at all you know
i i i think actually at least one thing
you could take from this
is that it turns out uh in fact that
white people did not invent wars of
conquest did not invent
genocide uh did not invent slavery
all that stuff had been happening in the
world has been happening in the world
for thousands and thousands and
thousands of years this is just one
example i don't know if that was her
point
but that is that is one historical
fact that you can take from this and to
put things in context and i think
especially these days
that is some useful context to have and
finally um
let's see here this is a report in the
daily wire i actually haven't read
through this yet i'm just grabbing it
based on the headline so
let's dive in it says in a piece
originally titled
there's a sinister reason coloring books
are so popular in quarantine a professor
who teaches the history of
the history of art ideas and technology
at stanford university and also writes
for the guardian in vogue
posits a unique take what if the recent
popularity of coloring books comes not
from the
creativity they purportedly inspire but
from the submission they induce
in the in the piece later we titled the
dark forgotten history of coloring books
uh emmanuel lugely asserts
this after all has been their mission
from the start it may be lost to the
fans of coloring books that their
success peaked in the 19th century when
such publications taught children how to
behave
and obedience seems to be what many of
us crave in these pandemic days
notice yeah of course that it may be
lost to the fans of color
well the fans of coloring books for the
most part are seven years old so yes i'm
sure this is lost on them
i mean my seven-year-old has never asked
me about the history of coloring books
i'd be a little freaked out if she did
noting that the the little folks
painting book often described as the
first coloring book which depicts in its
last story a brother and sister who
wished to fly away from their boring
secluded life
um lugely asks uh does this semma
sum up what coloring books are about
stay within the lines
and then all right it goes on so okay
this is this is as crazy as i hoped it
would be so i'm i'm
encouraged by that uh and i like where
it's going
my only concern is that doesn't go quite
far enough
yes coloring books teach submission um
so there's that but what about i mean
they also teach
a form of blackface and cultural
appropriation because think about it
you're taking these white characters
usually and coloring them much like
ralph northam
you're taking these pasty white uh
figures and putting artificial color on
them so i think that this encourages
children to perform blackface not only
that but
coloring books are transphobic
because for for some reason
that i'm i'm oh because they they
trivialize
body dysmorphia
by allowing you to change the physical
characteristics of the characters in the
coloring book so easily
thereby cheapening the lived experience
of dysmorphic individuals got it
okay so you can add on to this this this
so i'm a little bit disappointed by this
professor
yeah you found one offensive aspect of
coloring books but what about everything
else so you got to go
you really got to go for the gusto on
these things well i hope you enjoyed
that clip from the matt walsh show if
you did go ahead and hit that subscribe
button right down there so you can stay
up to date on all of our future content